des passagers canadiens visiblement sera
la supposée dangerosité des boeing 737
max 8 n'altère pas la confiance qu'ils
vouent à leur compagnie air canada
stoneham canada canada prend des bonnes
dispositions donc je me sens en sécurité
si l'avion était autorisée de vol
j'estime qu'il est sûre en plus circuler
vin n'est pas une compagnie débutants ça
fait longtemps qu'ils sont là
lesquels je pense pas qu'ils aient
problème des passagers contraints de
rester 24 heures de plus en martinique
ils ont été entièrement prise en charge
par cette compagnie et même logé pour la
nuit dans des hôtels en bord de mer une
journée +1 martinique
donc il ya pire que ça ça a bien été
ça a été rapide envoyé dans une note
elle ça a bien été
dans les circonstances on juge scalia
canada ont très bien réagi et d'une
façon très professionnelle et très
rapide et c'est pas c'est un fait est un
cadeau jusqu'à ce matin
le canada résistait encore à la pression
internationale
mais peu avant midi le ministre des
transports a cédé désormais les boeing
737 max 8 ne sont plus autorisés à voler
au canada le départ pour montréal se
fait maintenant à bord d'un airbus a321